right so it doesn't start off too
dramatic right there's some turn it
follows the normal rules of a gp
okay you've got that common ratio there
but importantly they tell you that it
has a limiting sum
okay that means that we automatically
know some things about
this series more than if i just left
that off so what
condition what information can i add on
before i start any of the actual
questions
what can i say one is less than r is
less than one
good that common ratio must be between
-1 and you're going to start getting
sick of writing this ice cube so
it's fine just to say the absolute value
of r is less than one
those two are equivalent all right now
let me actually give you a situation
find the common ratio
r if the limiting sum equals five times
the first
term okay so let's try and break that
down what we're trying to find is r
is that equal to provided that the
limiting
sum
equals five times the first term
okay now being that we've got the
definition of all the terms
there right we can actually say what the
first term is what's it equal to
if this is what the term is it's just a
isn't it which is the way we normally
write it yeah
so it's five times the first term
okay so from here all you need to
remember is that
okay a limiting sum is equal to a given
thing for any gp which has one
right what's the formula
good okay fantastic
and what we try to find out what the
ratio is so you can see probably the
next thing i should do is
if i want to make another subject
okay i will multiply two in a second
there's something i can do to make
things simpler before i make them
i can probably get rid of these a's
right
right i can divide through by a okay
because i don't want to have a my final
answer
now by the way you can't always just
divide both sides of the equation
by a number right that number has to
follow certain rules
what kinds of problems or when would it
be a problem to divide both sides of the
equation
because it's zero that's right so i have
to be able to say at this point
right that a is not zero
okay so it's a little bit like you know
when you do an inequality
right and you multiply both sides by a
number and then you either
leave or you change the direction of the
inequality okay
and then you know oh it's because i'm
changing the direction because i'm
multiplying by negative number
or vice versa right in the same way i
divide by
a right i've canceled out so i want to
make mention of this fact okay
is it going to get you any marks no but
you're making a point of the fact that
you know you can't just simply cancel
out um bearing
that's right you need to be careful all
right now what
i think we have the suggestion for
multiplied across
five minus five ah okay so let's tidy up
bring that five
up over take the one over and there is
our answer okay
so that's that's not too problematic
that's fine
let's have a look at the next question
because there's an interesting thing
that i want to see if you can
help me work out so part b says find the
first three terms
we want to know what they are provided
that the second term is
six and the limiting sum is 27.
second term is six and the limiting sum
is 27. okay
now when we started this question over
here
right um they told us something about
the limiting sum
and its relationship to the first term
okay now that gives us
different information here so how would
you suggest that i set it up so that i
can actually solve this question
what would you write can you make the
first term five on four times
okay hold on a second um i think a and b
are different
i think and b are different questions i
think they're different questions okay
uh yeah they all start with kind of
independent premises
so hold on what do we know we know that
the second term is six
okay now if the second term is six what
will the next term be the third term
it'll be six times the ratio whatever
that happens to be right
now following the same logic what will
the first term
yeah i'm dividing to go in the other
direction
okay so i'll be able to work out those
now i probably should actually be adding
these because it is um
i am working out the sum right
now if i add up all of them the question
tells us that the limiting sum is
37 right so i can write this down
okay now let's have a look at this is
there any other information provided to
us
in the question no that's it isn't it
okay so this is basically what i have to
work with
basically what i have to work with now
before i do any operation on this
there's something i can do just like
over here
okay to make things a little simpler
rather than deal with such big numbers
you don't see it
any suggestions yeah
every term on this side is going to have
a 6 in it
and there's a 3 that factors into this
okay so i can replace it with
2 1 r plus 2 plus 2 r
and so on is going to equal
9 okay great now keep in mind
we're being asked what the first three
terms are which are these guys
not the next line because this is
actually a different series isn't it it
doesn't have a limiting sum of 27
anymore
okay so just file that away okay now
what can i use to help me actually work
out uh you know obviously you can see
if i know what r is then i'll know what
the first three terms are
okay so yeah okay so we're gonna go with
the
limiting sum right so that sum is equal
to a
on one minus
so the first term first term is
two over r yes
this is the whole thing that's mine
right then i'm divided by one minus r
okay now what
u cos multiply okay so i get
9 minus 9 r there
and then you multiply everything by r
okay
so we have 9 r minus 9 r squared equals
2.
we're all happy with that so far oh
that's true but i think we'll leave that
for them i thought i was so clever
i love your dismissive
it is a quadratic correct let's tidy it
up a little bit messy
okay are you happy with that i've got it
in general form now
okay so now we could probably i mean we
could go to quadratic formula
but do we really need to really
no come on this is not the hard effect
right yes
come on look at it you want a pair of
numbers that will help you can do it
however you like
the way i'm doing in my head yeah i want
not just 3 6 i want
negative 3 and negative 6 right so
here's the way i would write it
divide by nine okay with that
this is really divide by three and
divide by three again so it goes once
into each of these different factors
right so i'm gonna get three r minus one
three
r minus two so what's r equal to
uh
okay raised eyebrow
oh i are that
there are two solutions were you
expecting two solutions
do you think there are two solutions
could there be two different solutions
it's ours i'm gonna pause here for a
minute i'm gonna post in a minute this
is one of the lovely things i can do
with the lottery what's extra time i
um have now i don't have to teach you
everything about these kinds of things
in class
i'll let you have a think two solutions
what are you gonna do with it
do you think there are two do you think
there are not two
either way how could you settle it for
yourself that it's
one or the other or both okay so i'll
give you some time to have a think about
that
let you stew on it and then we'll come
together